this is the portova compressor terminal
near st petersburg where gas meant for
german markets is readied for delivery
and yet in these pictures excess gas is
being burned off
which is odd because for months the
volume of gas sent to germany via the
nordstream one network has been cut
and for the next three days nothing will
come through it
part of planned maintenance says gazprom
part of president vladimir putin's
politicking says germany
we are literally paying a price these
stoppages have been banded about in talk
shows and political speeches as a
rhetorical possibility over the summer
but it's not rhetoric it's a bitter
reality
which is why ministers have spent months
trying to find gas from other sources
part of the german government's coping
strategy depends on installations like
this one a gas storage facility at
ruedesdorf outside berlin here it's
already almost 95
full and 95
capacity is the target the german
government has set to be reached by the
first of november
but storage of gas is only one aspect of
the solution one analyst says in the
short term everyone is being urged to
use as little gas as possible reduce
demand in industry in households
wherever you can
and not only industrial processes but
also when and in heat and heating
systems but also when it comes to
electricity demand and that's precisely
why the government at the moment is
trying to encourage
all consumers all sectors to reduce
demand because that's what can bring
down
the consumption
in theory full gas storage will only
cover german needs for a few winter
months
which is why the government has been
building new liquefied natural gas
terminals on its north sea coast so that
the lng shipments it's been buying in
can help cover any shortfall in the
coldest months early next year
covering german needs in the longer term
involves breaking with russian fossil
fuels forever dominic kane al jazeera
rudesdorf